the family of a woman who disappeared
while on a cross-country road trip with
her fiance is desperately seeking
answers today
twenty-two-year-old gabrielle petitto
was reported missing over the weekend
her last location is believed to have
been in wyoming now police in florida
say her fiance is back in north port
florida where the couple was living
before the trip our national
correspondent jerica duncan spoke to the
missing woman's parents and step parents
me and brian just got up and got ready
made the bed in the tent
gabrielle petito was documenting her
cross-country adventure with her 23 year
old fiance brian laundry gabby pito
never goes outside
in late august their posts slowed down
and so did communication it's a
nightmare it's a parent's nightmare
gabby's mother nicole schmidt says she
last facetimed her daughter on august
23rd or 24th around the same time gabby
made this final instagram post just
describe for me what you remember was
there anything that stood out she seemed
fine she was
creating her new youtube video and she
was getting that posted she was excited
nicole says the final text she received
from her daughter's phone was on august
30 but she would not share that message
or say whether she believes if it
actually came from her daughter gabby
began her road trip from long island new
york on july 2nd after visiting for her
brother's graduation and was that the
last time both of you all
saw your daughter yes
that was the last time in person yes
she is last believed to have been in
grand teton national park in wyoming
after visiting utah the couple was
traveling in this white 2012 ford
transit van which police recovered in
florida
so
we are
right outside capitol reef right now the
couple has been living in florida
together for about two years according
to social media they got engaged in
2020. she's a beautiful free spirit just
wanting to
take a journey and have fun while she's
young gabby's father and stepmother say
they simply want answers coolest chick
you ever met
simple as that and
we need her back home
we did reach out to brian laundry's
attorney but have not heard back police
in florida told us they are processing
the couple's van for potential evidence
gabby petitto is around five foot five
and has several identifiable tattoos
including one on her forearm that says
let it be you know to see the strength
from this family at this time even the
father said you can't empathize with
what we're going through they just want
answers they just want to know that
their daughter is safe well it's now
become a national story and i think
that's good because the more attention
you get on it the more likely we are to
be able to find her yeah but what is
brian saying brian isn't saying anything
you know
he hasn't posted anything recently on
his instagram page again we did reach
out to the attorney we haven't heard
back perhaps we will soon um but when i
asked the parents about you know do you
think this is suspicious
anything about brian they said we cannot
comment yeah wow you know just
awful she's the oldest of six oh god so
you know again parents
just hoping that they well
we hope she's okay yes all right thank
you very much